und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend zu den neuen Begriffen die
wir im Zuge der Energiekrise
kennenlernen gehört die winterlücke sie
klafft im Januar und Februar weil das
sind den zwei Monaten noch nicht klappen
wird mit den Preis Bremsen für Gas und
Strom aus verwaltungstechnischen Gründen
sozusagen aber und das ist neu für
Januar und Februar soll es die
Entlastung trotzdem geben nur halt erst
rückwirkend hinzu kommt noch die
einmalige Soforthilfe im Dezember in der
Gas oder Fernwärme bezieht braucht
nächsten Monat keinen Abschlag zu zahlen
Mieter bekommen das mit der nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung erstattet wieder
ein ab Januar die energiepreisbremsen im
Detail aussehen erklärt Klausberg
klar ist so günstig wie einst wird
fossile Energie nie mehr sein nun aber
zeichnet sich ab wie die ampelbürger und
Wirtschaft entlasten will für Gas sollen
Haushalte und kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen für 80% ihres Verbrauchs
maximal 12 Cent die Industrie für 70% 7
Cent für Strom 40 bzw 13 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bezahlen darüber gelten
dann Marktpreise Energiesparen soll sich
auszahlen die Regierung orientiert sich
an den Empfehlungen der
Expertenkommission der Entwurf entlastet
Bürger und Wirtschaft aber deutlich
stärker
dass wir abweichend großzügiger sind
also den Januar und den februar
ebenfalls noch mit einbeziehen in die
jetzt gültige dann zu verrechnen der
Gas- und strompreisbremse liegt schlicht
daran dass wir die Entlastungswirkung
jetzt in diesen Wintermonaten spürbar
und deutlich werden lassen wollen ist
also eine politische Entscheidung die
über den Vorschlag der Kommission
hinausgeht weil die energieversorge erst
ab März in der Lage sind die
gaspreisbremse technisch umzusetzen soll
sie für Januar und Februar einfach
rückwirkend angerechnet werden also
erstmal halt nichts für gut dass jetzt
tatsächlich die Hoffnung besteht ein
schnelles Gesetzgebungsverfahren noch in
diesem Jahr zu haben damit die
Entlastung in dem Fall der Unternehmen
auch zügig passieren kann zum ersten
Januar das ist gut und wichtig für
Unternehmen die unter hohen
Energiepreise stehen kritik kommt von
der Opposition es kommt zu
ungewöhnlichen Allianzen wenn man das
liest ist es gerade für die Unternehmen
für die indust die für Mittelstand
Handwerk in Deutschland sehr sehr
kompliziert das durchblickt kaum ein
Abgeordneter geschweige denn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und für die
Betriebe ist es so dass es überhaupt
keine Planbarkeit gibt einfacher
schneller sozial gerechter wären direkte
Zahlungen des Staats an die Bürger sagen
Verbraucherschützer wir hatten uns eine
Direktzahlung von der Regierung direkt
an ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger gewünscht
das ist in Deutschland derzeit aber
nicht möglich dieser auszahlungsweg muss
dringend und schnell entwickelt werden
das fordern wir seit zwei Jahren so oder
so Energiesparen lohnt sich auch weiter
und noch eine sozialpolitische
Entscheidung gab es heute in Berlin nach
zähmen hin und her wo da einen
Kompromiss für das neue Bürgergeld
gefunden weil das Gesetz durch den
Bundesrat muss konnte die ampelregierung
ihre Reformpläne nicht im Alleingang
durchsetzen sondern musste sich mit CDU
und CSU einigen Fraktionschef Friedrich
Merz erklärte heute die unionsregierten
Länder sein nach diversen Änderungen
nunmehr bereit im Bundesrat zuzustimmen
gestört hatte die Union vor allem dass
die Ampel weniger Sanktionen für
hilfe-mann mit den Einzelheiten
die Ampel trägt schwarz zwar ist das
Bürgergeld gerettet die vertrauenszeit
aber ist tot sie war das Signal für die
neue Zeit in der den Arbeitslosen auf
Augenhöhe begegnet statt mit
Leistungskürzung gedroht werden soll
Sanktionen greifen nun sofort nicht nur
wenn Termine verpasst werden und die
grüne Fraktionschefin trauert die
vertrauenszeit sie ist nicht mehr
vorgesehen in dem
Einigungsvorschlag oder in dem
Textvorschlag der jetzt morgen
Gegenstand der Beratung im
Vermittlungsausschuss sein wird
ich bedauere das sehr genau das feiert
die Union als ihren Triumph bei den
Verhandlungen diese vertrauenszeit wird
komplett gestrichen und damit ist im
Grunde genommen auch der Kern des
Bürgergelds so wie die Koalition ist
geplant hat komplett gestrichen
in den informellen Gesprächen zwischen
Opposition und Regierung noch vor der
Sitzung des Vermittlungsausschusses
morgen Abend wurde auch die Karenzzeit
in der Wohnung und Vermögen der
Leistungsbezieher unangetastet bleiben
von 24 auf 12 Monate gekürzt und beim
Schonvermögen darf der Haushaltsvorstand
nun nicht mehr 60.000 sondern nur noch
40.000 Euro behalten für jede weitere
Person im Haushalt sind es statt 30.000
jetzt 15.000 Euro der Kanzler bleibt
dennoch dabei alles Folge seine
Masterplan
eine sehr wir wollen ja jetzt eine ganz
große Sozialreform beschließen die dann
jahrzehntelang in Deutschland die Art
und Weise der Förderung von
Arbeitssuchenden
beschreibt und das wird uns davon bin
ich jetzt fest überzeugt gelingen
Sozialverbände und die Linke bemängeln
dass der angeblich große Wurf viel zu
knauserig sei nun mehr denn je ich will
in großer Deutlichkeit sagen dass die
angekündigte größte Sozialreform seit 20
Jahren doch extrem verwässert worden ist
man kann feststellen dass Hartz IV
weiterlebt es gibt eine Einigung von
Union und Ampel die letztlich auf dem
Rücken der Betroffenen stattgefunden hat
wenn das Gesetz am Freitag durch den
Bundesrat geht dann wird es mehr
gezielte Fortbildungen für Arbeitslose
geben mehr Möglichkeiten für sie dazu zu
verdienen insgesamt mehr fördern als
fördern und 5,4 Millionen der ärmsten
bekommen 53 Euro mehr im Monat besser
als nicht
und jetzt gibt es noch einen
schwungnachrichten von Heinz Wolf im
Bundestag hat die Schlussrunde der
Haushaltsberatung begonnen die
Opposition war auf Bundesfinanzminister
Lindner vor viel zu hohe Schulden neben
dem Bundeshaushalt zu machen Lindner
verteidigte seine etapplanung der
Haushalt für 2023 sieht ein Volumen von
476,3 Milliarden Euro und eine
Neuverschuldung von
45,6 Milliarden Euro vor Ende der Woche
soll der Etat verabschiedet werden
die Bundeswehr soll ihren aktuell
größten Auslandseinsatz im
westafrikanischen Mali bis spätestens
Mai 2024 beenden das gab die
Bundesregierung bekannt Deutschland
stellt bislang Soldaten für eine Mission
der Vereinten Nationen derzeit etwa 1200
auf der indonesischen Insel Java ist
nach dem schweren Erdbeben gestern die
Zahl der Todesopfer auf mindestens 268
gestiegen er ist 1000 Menschen wurden
verletzt am stärksten betroffen ist die
Stadt chiantur dort suchen die
Einsatzkräfte unter den eingestürzten
Gebäuden weiter nach Verschütteten
indonesienspräsident wie Dodo versprach
Hilfe für einen schnellen Wiederaufbau
die katholischen Bischöfe in Deutschland
liberalisieren das Arbeitsrecht ihrer
Kirche künftig gehen persönliche Aspekte
wie Homosexualität Scheidung oder
widerheirat den kirchlichen Arbeitgebern
nichts mehr an vielfach wird aus
Vielfalt wird ausdrücklich als
Bereicherung anerkannt 800.000 Menschen
arbeiten für die katholische Kirche in
Deutschland und jetzt muss jedes Bistum
das neue Arbeitsrecht einzeln umsetzen
die isolationspflicht für
corona-infizierte wird in weiteren
Bundesländern aufgehoben nach Bayern
Baden-Württemberg und Schleswig-Holstein
gehen auch Hessen und Rheinland-Pfalz
diesen Weg Hessen ab morgen
Rheinland-Pfalz ab Samstag noch kurz zu
den Wetteraussichten morgen scheint
zunächst im Süden und Osten die Sonne
allerdings sieht es von Westen her zu
und es setzt Regen ein die Temperaturen
erreichen höchste Werte zwischen 4 und
12 Grad und der Wind weht halt stark aus
südlichen Richtungen in den nächsten
Tagen kommt weiterhin milde Luft nach
Deutschland dazu auch Regen bei vier bis
zwölf Grad
so viel von uns weiter geht es mit der
zweiten Halbzeit und gegen 0.50 meldet
sich dann Gundula Gause mit unserem
heute schon mal Update bis morgen dann
zu gewohnter Zeit und in voller Länge
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]